[Music]
you read if I made a Cochrane and joggle
I'll be waiting
dad sorry what was that last thing you
said what that last part they didn't
catch it well is anything what do you
mean I didn't like I said I'll be
waiting and then I stopped talking dad
no Lloyd that's right your son and it's
Lloyd no ll o yd I named you you've
ruined my life that's not true I haven't
even been a part of your life how could
I ruin it wasn't even there baby now we
got bad
I'm kicking their Salamone - from the
secret ninja force
are you ready to risk your life but
Ninjago yes I am Allah may be gone I'm
stuck I know you want me to save myself
so I'll go now I promise I'll never
forget you I didn't ask you to promise
that come back
hello who is this Lloyd Garmadon your
son hmm I must have butt-dialed you
it's okay Lloyd nobody's parents are
perfect I mean my mom is weird and
collects seashells
your dad levels cities and attacks
innocent people so they've all got that
quarks you know
you